bonjour hello all good afternoon
today I am very pleased to announce that
the report of the public order
commission public order emergency
commission has been submitted to
Parliament
it will soon be available on the
commission's website
I would like to firstly acknowledge that
I am making this statement from the
traditional territory of the Algonquin
and ishnavig people
at the National Archives of Canada just
steps away from where many of the events
that led to this inquiry took place
the public order emergency commission
was established on April 25th 2022 as a
result of the government of Canada's
decision to invoke the emergencies act
in response to protests
in Ottawa and elsewhere in Canada
in January and February of 2022. the
commission was directed to examine and
report on the circumstances that led to
the Declaration of a public order
emergency
and the measures taken by the government
for dealing with the emergency
the commission was also tasked with
examining to the extent relevant to the
circumstances of the Declaration of
emergency and the measures taken
the following questions the evolution
and goals of the Convoy and blockades
their leadership organization and
participants
the impact
of domestic and foreign funding
including crowdsourcing platforms
the impact role and sources of
misinformation and disinformation
including
the use of social media
impact of the blockades including their
economic impact and the efforts of
police and other responders prior to and
after the Declaration
this was a Monumental task for the
commission
particularly in light of the fact that
this report
had to be completed in less than 300
days
thanks to the hard work and dedication
of too many people
to name
them I'm proud to say that we have
carried out the important task
assigned to us by Parliament
we've produced a thorough
and comprehensive report and we have met
the deadline set by the statute
location of too many people to name I'm
proud to say that we have carried out
the important task assigned to us by
Parliament
produced a thorough and comprehensive
report and met the deadline set by
Statute
on previous occasions I've said that
this commission's task is first and
foremost
a tool to be a tool of accountability
and to Foster Public confidence
the invocation of the emergencies Act
was a significant event members of the
public
have a right to know
that what the government did and why
they did it
the commission has already contributed
to the Public's right to know through
its public hearings for over 30 days in
October just November and December
2022 the commission heard from 76
Witnesses and 50 experts
many senior government officials were
examined both by commission Council and
by Council for the 22 parties to whom
the commission granted standing to
participate in the hearings
the witnesses who testified included
organizers of the Convoy citizens
affected by the protests police public
servants and the elected officials at
the municipal and federal levels
even the Prime Minister testified
providing his own account of the events
in question
there was also
unprecedented access to documents
produced by Duff dozens of different
entities including the federal
government
commission Council where security
cleared and able to review documents
that were otherwise classified or
protected by National Security or other
public interest privilege
for only the fourth time in Canadian
history cabinet confidence was waived
over records containing the inputs that
were before cabinet
when it deliberated over the use of the
emergencies Act
approximately 28 000 documents were
disclosed to the party through
participated in the hearings and
approximately nine thousand of those
were introduced into evidence
permeal
the proceedings became a rare public
examination of decision making by the
federal and other governments and
government agencies
thousands of people watched the
proceedings
read the transcripts and examined the
exhibits
from these proceedings the public has
already been exposed to an immense
amount of information
individuals have been able to form their
own views about the events of early 2022
today with the publication of my report
the commission contributes to public
accountability in a second way
by setting out my findings conclusions
and recommendations following the events
in question
my report contains over 2 000 pages
spread across five volumes
it consists of an executive summary two
volumes of analysis a detailed record of
the commission's activities
a report summarizing the over 8 800
submissions received in our public
consultation process
and a collection of expert policy papers
produced for the commission
in the report I Chronicle the origins of
the freedom Convoy I conclude that it
was not an organization with clear
leadership rather it was a movement
comprised of people who shared certain
social economic and political grievances
but also had countless individual views
many of the protesters concerns long
predated covid-19 pandemic
they were rooted in feelings of loss of
place within Canadian Society alienation
economic anxieties and loss of faith in
government
that said the pandemic and responding
Public Health measures were an important
motivator that caused the freedom Convoy
to mobilize
some will want my report to make
findings or conclusions about covet
itself
or the correctness of how government
responded to it those people may be
disappointed my mandate is not about the
pandemic or public health policy those
are important topics but not ones with
which I have been tasked
I do however make two observations
first the covid-19 pandemic was perhaps
a once in a generation crisis
governments Federal provincial Municipal
responded in good faith to circumstances
as they understood them
second however however one views those
responses they imposed real hardships on
thousands of Canadians
people did not only lose family and
friends to the disease
some also lost jobs businesses homes and
savings many more such as health care
workers labored under extremely
difficult circumstances
truckers were another group that felt a
heavy weight
from the pandemic
sometimes made more difficult by Health
measures
put in place by governments
when new rules that limited the ability
of unvaccinated truckers to cross the
Canada U.S border were announced
this served as a rallying point for
those who disagreed with government
policy
these individuals organized mobilized
and became what would come to be known
as the freedom Convoy movement
one of the most cherished rights enjoyed
by Canadians is the right to engage in
political protest
the ability of individuals and groups to
publicly voice their dissent enriches
and empowers our democracy it's hardly
surprising that government Health
measures would cause some form of
protest in response
given their impact on people's lives
what was surprising was the size and
scale of these protests and the way in
which they proliferated across the
country
the majority of those who participated
in the protest were animated by a
genuine desire
to engage in peaceful demonstrations so
that their voices would be heard by
leaders in government
they wish to exercise their fundamental
right to express their political views
and they had a right to do so
however like any large group there were
a diversity of views
and intentions among the participants of
the freedom Convoy
amongst the many who intended to protest
peacefully were others
who had more Sinister goals or who were
willing to engage in dangerous conduct
to achieve their desired ends for
reasons that I discuss in my report what
began as a massive protest evolved into
something entirely unpre unprecedented
an occupation of the core of the
nation's capital
the events of January and February 2022
were not limited to Ottawa
as I describe in my report
protests were occurring across the
country in places such as Coots Alberta
Emerson Manitoba and Windsor Ontario
these protests were also diverse
they ranged from peaceful marches to
blockades of critical infrastructure
the size and scope of these protests was
truly unprecedented police and
governments alike struggled to respond
ultimately the federal government's
response was to declare a public order
emergency
is what role I should play in assessing
cabinets decision to invoke the
emergencies Act
there's no precedent that helps to
answer that question
some parties have argued that I should
not opine on the appropriateness of the
seat of the decision and
whether government met the statutory
requirement to declare the public
emergency order was not within my
mandate
they note quite properly that
determining the legality
of the government's actions is the role
of the Courts of law
others however have argued that
pronouncing on the decision
is the result date the the very reason
for this Commission
in my view the role and focus of a
commission of inquiry into the use of
the emergencies act will depend
to a certain extent on the context in
which the ACT is invoked
in some instances
it may be on doubt that the conditions
the for invoking the ACT were met
but there may be other questions that
require careful review
in the present situation however I'm
faced with a statute that has never been
used or judicially interpreted
serious questions have been raised as to
whether the legal threshold to use the
ACT have been met
my assessment of the circumstances
surrounding the invocation of the ACT
therefore
inevitably involved a consideration
of the acts requirements
while nothing in my report is in any
sense binding on the courts
that may hear legal challenges to the
use of the ACT I have decided to set out
my own views on the invocation of the
Act and the measures taken under it
after careful reflection
I have concluded that the very high
threshold required for the invocation of
the ACT
was met
in particular for reasons that I discuss
in detail in the report I have concluded
that when the decision was made to
invoke the act on February 14 2022
cabinet had reasonable grounds to
believe
that there existed a national emergency
arising from threats to the security of
Canada
that necessitated The Taking of special
temporary measures
I do not come to this conclusion easily
as I do not consider the factual basis
for it to be overwhelming
reasonable and informed people could
reach a different conclusion that the
one I have arrived at
Premier Reflections
after careful reflection I have
concluded that the very high threshold
required for the invocation of the Act
was met
in particular for reasons that I discuss
in detail in the report I've concluded
that when the decision was made to
invoke the act on February 14 2022
cabinet had reasonable grounds to
believe
that there existed a National Emergency
arising from threats to the security of
Canada that necessitated
The Taking of special temporary measures
I do not come to this conclusion easily
as I do not consider the factual basis
for it to be overwhelming
reasonable and informed people could
reach a different conclusion than the
one I've arrived at
I also reached this conclusion
reluctantly
the state should generally be able to
respond to circumstances of urgency
without the use of emergency powers
it is only in truly rare instances when
the state reasonably believes that it
cannot otherwise fulfill its fundamental
obligation to ensure the safety and
security of people and property that
resort to emergency measures will be
appropriate
in other words the emergencies Act is
not a tool of convenience
but rather
it is a tool of Last Resort
the fact that circumstances evolved to
the point where cabinet reasonably
considered it necessary to invoke the
ACT is regrettable because in my view
the situation that led to its use
could likely have been avoided
as I have explained in my report the
response to the freedom Convoy included
a series of policing failures though I
have also identified sound practices
employed by some police services in
their response
to relevant events
some of the missteps may have been small
but others were significant
taken together they contributed to a
situation that spun out of control
the failures were not only in policing
preparing for and responding to
situations of threat and urgency in a
federal system requires governments at
all levels
and those who lead them to rise above
above politics and collaborate for the
common good
in January and February 2022
this did not always happen
had police forces and governments better
anticipated and prepared for the extent
of political and social discontent
exacerbated by covid-19 pandemic
particularly in the environment of
misinformation and disinformation so
prevalent today
and had they collaborated more
effectively there could have been a
different response
to this unprecedented situation
it's likely that such preparation could
have avoided the necessity of invoking
the emergencies Act
uh
in addition to making findings on the
invocation of the act itself I've also
reached conclusions on the
appropriateness and effectiveness of the
measures taken under it
while I have ultimately concluded that
the federal government was justified in
invoking the act
I reach a more qualified conclusion with
respect to the measures that the
government adopted
I determined that the measures taken by
the federal government were for the most
part appropriate and effective and
contributed to bringing a return to
order without loss of life or Serious
injury to people or property
I also found however that in a number of
respects these measures were deficient
these included important aspects of the
emergency economic measures order such
as the absence of any discretion related
to freezing assets
and the failure to provide a clear way
for individuals to have their assets
unfrozen
when they were no longer engaged in
illegal conduct
I determined that the measures taken by
the federal government were for the most
part appropriate and effective and
contributed to bringing a return to
order without loss of life or Serious
injury to people or property I also
found however that in a number of
respects these measures were deficient
these included important aspects of the
emergency economic measures order such
as the absence of any discretion related
to the freezing of accounts or assets
and the failure to provide a clear way
for individuals to have their assets
unfrozen once they were no longer
engaged in legal conduct
I also discuss aspects of the emergency
measures regulations that caused me
concern including the vagueness of its
Provisions related to securing of places
and its potential impact on freedom of
the press
drawing on Lessons Learned through this
inquiry my report concludes with a set
of 56 recommendations
my recommendations relate to six broad
areas policing Federal intelligence
collection and coordination
critical trade corridors and
infrastructure
reforms to the emergencies Act
other areas for further study
and follow up an accountability
following the release of my reports
learn through this inquiry my report
concludes with a sec set of 56
recommendations
my recommendations relate to six broad
areas policing
Federal intelligence collection and
coordination
critical trade corridors and
infrastructure
reforms to the emergencies Act
other areas for further study and
follow-up and accountability following
the release of my report
I hope that these recommendations will
go some way to addressing the various
issues and deficiencies of a systemic
nature that I identify in my report
before ending these remarks I would like
to make a few comments about the
emergencies act itself
I have already commented that it is
regrettable that the situation across
Canada deteriorated to the point where
cabinet reasonably believed that the use
of the Act was necessary
we can all hope that such an exceptional
Confluence of events and circumstances
does not occur again
however even if it does and if once
again the very high threshold
for declaring an emergency is met
members of the public should recognize
that the ACT contains significant
safeguards
although the emergencies Act is often
referred to as a replacement
for the war measures act it is in fact a
very different statute
the emergencies Act was designed to
respond to a much broader range of
emergencies it was also intentionally
designed to provide extensive checks
balances and limits
to guard against abuse
there are significant limits on the
kinds of measures that the government
can take during an emergency
the law permits legal challenges to use
of the Act and the measures adopted
under it must remain compliant with the
Canadian Charter of Rights and Freedoms
Parliament is given extensive powers of
review and control over the executive's
use of the ACT
although cabinet can unilaterally
declare an emergency
Parliament can revoke the Declaration at
any time
and of course a commission such as this
one is mandatory
provided that future commissions are
like this one was created pursuant to
the inquiries act and
given access to the necessary documents
and information
they will ensure that the government's
contact will be subject to meaningful
independent scrutiny
it is notable that the protections that
the emergencies act contains far exceed
those of any provincial or territorial
emergencies statutes in Canada
and even
in other countries across the world
well I have made recommendations for
various reforms to bring the emergencies
act into the 21st century to ensure the
effectiveness of future inquiries and
to strengthen government accountability
I am also convinced that there is much
in the act
that is commendable
the Parliament that passed the
emergencies act in 1988 went to Great
Lengths to ensure that its use would be
subject
to robust accountability
and public scrutiny
I hope that this inquiry and my report
have contributed to achieving this
Parliament that passed the emergencies
act in 1988
went to Great Lengths to ensure that its
use would be subject to robust
accountability and public scrutiny
I hope that this inquiry
and my report have contributed to
achieving this
merci beaucoup thank you
enjoy the report